we try and keep up with what's going on
over at cnn and a few nights ago we told
you about cnn anchor brooke baldwin
she's on her way out but on our way out
she accused he ended up being sexist and
you may recall we gave the advice to
jeff zucker just transition
and increase the number of women at cnn
but he ignored our advice
instead the channel is doubling down on
women hating
watch this well a couple of things i
don't know everybody else's salary
so i can't say that it's a you know and
it's a
boys club i look i just got there you
don't think it's a boys club as as
i don't i don't think you're having
lunch with zucker i'm guessing she's
not well i don't know who's i mean i
actually called him up and said would
you like to have lunch i mean she can do
the same thing
remember mr rourke from love boat why is
it don lamont every time or so you get a
sort of
mr rook from anyway he was asked about
brook baldwin's claims
and he said i just got here of course
he's only been there 15
years time moves quickly when you work
in a cable patriarchy
once you get past mr lamont's denial we
did notice something else
he was mansplaining if you can imagine
like sitting knees open on the subway
lecturing brook baldwin on how to get
invited to the bro
lunch with jeff zucker now we know that
don lemon might not strike you as the
poster child for toxic masculinity but
that's exactly what that was casual
sexism he doesn't even realize it
don lemon needs to check himself and his
male privilege
stop the mansplaining mr rourke
that's it for us